Kidney stone symptoms showing up anything more I could do so this person has got kidney stones
May have had kidney stones in the past now. They're getting symptoms of kidney stones
What can they do? I'm using the right lemon juice olive oil plus homeopathic pills
Also, what are your thoughts on C. Cucumber? Yeah, give it a try. There's also a product by herb farm. That's called stone breaker
I can't remember the ingredients in it, but I we've had a lot of people that have used that for kidney stones
I'd give if I had kidney stones that we tried anything to help with kidney stones
You could
Yeah, those are the things that I that I would think of make sure you're obviously you're drinking lots of water
And trying to flush those I
I've never had a kidney stone, but I've heard there's the most painful thing that a person could go through
So I feel for you will definitely be praying for this person with kidney stones extremely painful
Hey, we're talking about paid you know the thing that we just talked about in this may help the pain of a kidney stone
It's not gonna help a kidney stone pass, but it may help the pain